[Music]
all right thanks everyone for being
there
my name is frien I'm walking at Google
as a software engineer on the Android
games team and there is two things that
I like in life it's making applications
and video games that's why I created the
develop it's an open-source
cross-platform game creator that people
can use to create any kind of 2d games
and it's a visual editor for games so
there is a level editor that I will show
just after and there is some kind of
visual programming so that anyone can
create games the rules of the game
without having to really do any kind of
coding and at the end you're getting
some html5 games that can be outputted
and played in a web browser or even on
Android iOS or on desktop so that's what
the software used to look like I say
used to because at the old version so it
was all written in C++ as a desktop
application that you could download for
Windows Mac OS Linux so I will quickly
show you oh it was walking and the
visual programming I was talking about
so you can see that there is the level
editor on the left it's done using
OpenGL and you can create the level of
the game and on the right there is a
list of objects that are in your game so
for example you have two player the
platforms the button that is in the
middle of the screen and so on and what
I want to do is to add some rules to the
game so that when the player is stepping
on the button then the platform that is
on the right is going a bit up in the
air so that the player can step on it
and continue in the level so let's see
how to do it so I'm putting the button
on the level and now I'm adding with
visual events so evens are composed of
condition and actions here I'm adding a
condition to tell that if there is a
collision between the player and the
button then in this case I will launch
two actions it's if
so the first action will be to change
the animation of the button so that it
goes in the state where it's pressed and
then I'm adding another action which is
one to move yet to add a force to add so
that to the platform is moving up in the
air so on the y axis I'm adding of force
and now I can press play and the world
game is compiled to JavaScript and it's
run in a browser and when I'm stepping
on the button yeah it's walking so see
it's fairly simple it's it's programming
but for people that don't want or don't
have the time to learn a new programming
language and it's working very well
people have been creating lots of
different games with this I've done the
one with the cat on the top left and
fixed we are going alright but at some
point the Wally detour was getting quite
old I have lots of cross-platform issues
with the UI toolkit and especially on
Mac OS and Linux fins were crashing from
time to time and iterating of the
software was quite slow C++ building the
UI was slow and I was limited to all UI
components the native one and honestly
the UX would need quite a lot of
enhancements and also the entry barrier
for new contributor was quite I suppose
again so ya know it's time for me to
react and my question was could the web
technologies help because I've been
using quite a lot of react before my
preview job and was like I feel that's a
better way to do things I think that
it's perfect for making complex UI oh is
it really
can we have frogs a whole list of trees
and of Android of elements dynamic
panels 3d visualization nested dialogs
drag and drop search and everything then
make your app looks like a real
distribution rather than a web app can
we make ambitious applications same with
JavaScript is perfect for most
applications
oh really what if we haven't already
existing native code base like I do oh
if we want to do advanced computation or
if we need consistent performance well
let's let's
this is the world C++ code days of the
software well that was the code base so
that was in the middle of the code base
the core classes what a game is what an
object is what the texture is and the
game in the game exporter so that's
taking this model of a game and
transpiling it to JavaScript as a WebGL
game and on top of it there was
everything related to the graphic
interface and the file system so I was
thinking okay I could redo the whole
interface using react and for the file
system I could change it to use natural
essence also browser adapters and run
the wolf in on not Jas or Chrome or run
it or package it using electrons so that
I have an affection that people can
download and what to do with the C++
code base when I could compile it to
webassembly let's see this part so if
you don't know about webassembly it's a
low-level language that is running in
your browser in only valgrind browser
it's supported by even on mobile phones
on Android and iOS and it's a low-level
language meaning that you're not writing
web assembly and but you're compiling
from another language to web assembly
and it's running fast it's running fast
because as it's assembly like browser
can optimize it much more quickly than
JavaScript and you get consistent
performance so I said that we are not
writing directly to webassembly but
using things like for example Emscripten
which is a project to compile from c++
to web assembly or using a language like
reversed all the languages that are
combining to web assembly or you can
even try it using assembly script which
is a long range that looks like
typescript and that combines to twelve
assembly in my case I've been using apps
Krypton because I had this C++ code base
that I wanted to port on the web so I
will describe how it work and then we'll
see the the part about remaking the
world interface in react
so first webassembly sorry first
Emscripten
if you want to try it it's not that
complicated you have to clone the SDK
with those comments that I won't detail
and then you're getting
a compiler called EMCC that you can run
on the C or C++ file and you're getting
as the output a J's file that is running
a web assembly file for larger projects
Emscripten is providing you with a
replacement for your compiler so that
you can swap your your project build and
instead of getting a binary you will be
getting a web assembly module so in my
case I'm using sinmec but depends on
what could be Co you're trying to port
to the web so if you're compiling the
wulfing to webassembly you have this
huge chunk of C++ compiler web assembly
and that's not enough you have to expose
the existing classes in in C++ or worse
or whatever you don't go age so that you
can use them in JavaScript let's take an
example here is a layout it's it's a
scene it's a level of a game it's it's a
C++ class and you can set the name get
the name of the scene and can insert or
get an object on the scene though that's
just an example we don't really care
about what's inside the fiscal the idea
is that you are you have to write the
interface so that inscription can know
what classes to expose to JavaScript so
that looks like this there are multiple
ways of doing it in my case I've been
using something called web IDL it's an
interface definition language it's used
by the w3c to write the specification
for the Dom it's also we can also use it
to to show to inscription what should be
exposed to JavaScript so here
I'm rewriting the interface of the class
the layout with two methods that name
gain name and two the method to insert
and get an object you can see that the
type are slightly different and the idea
that you have to look at the
documentation of Emscripten or your
language to see what type are being
converted in your language and to to
JavaScript once you have it you can run
it and Emscripten will be compiling your
C++ code to web assembly and including
these bindings that you've been writing
generating some kind of glue code that
is calling from so that when you call
the JavaScript class it's inside it's
calling webassembly that looks like this
at the end you have a module that you
instantiate getting the the object in a
promise and then you can create a new
object here layout call a function on it
like that name
same with other objects and you can even
console.log the result of a method
returning returning a string and that's
that's working well the primitive types
like number of billions automatically
converted to the equivalent in in your
own language so again look at the
documentation to see for example the
JavaScript strings are converted to an
array of characters in NC if you pass an
object you will get a reference to an
object or pointer in C++ and if you want
to put things in the console in CS
pressed will be automatically redirected
to the console in your in your debugger
so that's what you are getting if you're
running the world library in the chrome
debugger so you can see that on the top
there are some logs that are outputted
by the C++ library so it's it's walking
and then you can create an object and
call the method and get the result of
another one so yeah you are being
something walking in your browser even
if it's written in C++ or restos off or
something else so that's a pretty good
first step there are a few things to
know first the memory management
requires care because if you're creating
something in the web assembly warned you
have to destroy it
meaning that let me explain if you
creating a layout which is an object
written in my library if you consult
that log it you see that it's not a real
JavaScript object it's a JavaScript
object containing a pointer to some to
some number which is a number that is
pointing to some part of the web
assembly memory you can think of the web
assembly memory as a big array that is
empty at the beginning and when you're
creating a new object the web a solid
code
running some constructor odds create new
objects in memory and so it's an array
of bits basically if you don't destroy
it if you just forget about this layout
variable in your JavaScript then the
reference to this memory is lost forever
basically you have a memory leak so you
have to remember to call the GD when the
module dot destroy method that will be
basically running the destructor in c++
rust whatever and we'll really the
memory so that's something that you have
to remember to do and for example if
you're using a react that means that
when you're mounting a component if
you're creating an object in the web
assembly world be sure to destroy it
when the component is unwanted oh you
can use an effective second thing to
know that the output of the web assembly
model will be quite large it's three
megabytes for G develop you can can
compress it and it's only a few
megabytes honestly I don't really care
because I'm making an application that
is a rich application so a few megabytes
more or less that's the same I'm happy
I'm not happy but I'm fine with user
having to wait a bit during the loading
time of the application to get this
because it's a rich experience and so
the wulfing can be downloaded using
electron which is a few Android megabyte
so one more one less something some last
thing to know is that you better have a
complete test set for your library that
is confined to web assembly because this
is the kind of error that you're getting
is something is going wrong in your web
assembly module so it's not it's not
useful at all and that can happen if for
example you pass a wrong type of
parameter to a method or you forget a
parameter in this case you're you your
web assembly code will be expecting for
example a pointer to an object
if you pass instead a number which is
meaning nothing then it will go to some
place in the memory where there is
garbage and bad things will happen that
can also be the case if you are using a
deleted object the best things are a bit
manual walk that we are not used to do
in JavaScript but once you get used to
it it's it's fine and it's a it's mainly
to remember to always use an object
after creating it and deleting it and to
pass to make sure to pass the proper
types for the parameters this being said
we now have the the core of the of the
application that is compiled to web
assembly and running in a browser that's
a good first step let's now see if we
can redo an interface on top of it that
is better than what we had before so we
want to make a complex UI and by complex
UI I mean a UI with context menu
thumbnails list of objects trees dialogs
so the first thing I wanted to do was to
find a component library material you
iraq toolbox blueprint whatever my idea
was to find something with an extensive
list of high-quality components good
theming support accessibility maybe the
most important thing and a good
documentation quality in my case I've
been using metal UI but others can be
fine too
then the first change I had when we were
making this world interface in Arad was
to display large lists of objects and
when I say large it's sometimes hundreds
of animals or thousands first of all the
list of objects in a game in this case
using V authorized list has been really
useful using your files upon reactor to
rise don't react window and the idea is
that instead of just mapping on a list
of objects and displaying all of them in
the Dom in the browser the
virtualization library will give you a
list component with a function here
called Ravinder and this function will
be called to render only a subset of the
list which is the object data to display
on the screen so if your screen is
displaying 20 objects you will only have
in the dom
20 object rather than a thousand and
then when you're scoring some object are
being removed from the dom and other I
did you can even use react GND if you
want to add drag and dropped to the via
tries list and it's working very well
the next trend that I had was to display
some panels or resizable editor because
as I'm making I'm making a game engine a
gimme detour people want to be able
customize their workspace and it's not
something that we used to do on the web
but turns out that there are libraries
that are doing this for us so basically
you take a look at react mosaic it's
awesome because it's giving you a kind
of yeah window management library that
is doing everything for you and so you
can have a workspace that user can
customize so it's very great then this
next wrench was to display large trees
on the on the screen so you can see
that's the event editor that was done on
the left in C++ in the native
application it was quite complex and
honestly out to maintain it was a 2,000
line of C++
so here I've been using again another
library to make this tree of events
because events can observe events it's a
bit like cut blocks that can have sub
well not events but also cut blocks
nested inside anyway here the
authorization again is really useful
I've been using a react saw table tree
which is giving you a good start if you
want to make some kind of no business
rules that you can drag and drop on the
screen in my case I'm using a customized
version of it and I think maybe the most
complex thing to do was to remake the
world level editor that was done before
in OpenGL and know that I wanted to have
on the web at this point using the dome
was not an option anymore
you can forget about it and start to
think about using WebGL well using WebGL
it's a bit harder to make to get started
so I've been using a library which is
called pixie J's which is it's it's a
rendering library rendering on on WebGL
or canvas and there is also phaser 3d is
any way think about it if you have to do
something that is a bit too complex for
the Dom like 2d rendering of some of
thousand of elements like you like your
level inner game still sometimes the Dom
can be useful let's say that you want to
have an little where you're displaying
the polygons to it box the collision
mask of often objects so in my case I
want people
be able in that game to say that this
red area is the place where the
spaceship of the player can be eat and
rest is fine in this case the dome using
SVG element can be really useful and
especially consider that you can use the
own pointer move up and down events you
can get a polygon that you can display
on the screen quite easily using a react
or your favorite from front-end
framework and yeah using this on pointer
move up and down events you can get
something that can be dragged and drop
on the screen so that I can go on on the
vertex and then drag it so you have a
visual read of a polygon and it's done
pretty easily sometimes things are not
fast enough meaning that things are too
slow to render on the screen in this
case the best bet is in the case of
react to use the react profiler so for
example if you have something that is
too slow to render take a look at the
profiler it's displaying in all the
components in your in your application
and it's coloring the component that
that are being rendered after an
interaction and so in my case you can
see that the left part is filled with
lots of colors and it's because some
panel that was not even displayed on the
screen has been rendered after each
interaction so that I was getting a lot
of well I was getting a performance hit
for something that was not even on the
screen so in this case the profiler is
really useful at least to sanity check
that you're not rendering more than
needed something to remember measure
performance of your application in
production at least in the case of react
and less familiar with other front-end
frameworks but in the case of react the
development build is way slower because
of the warnings so it can make a
difference something that is taking like
1 seconds in development can be a few
milliseconds or less in production and
sometimes things are slow because you're
not slow during the rendering but you're
cutting too much of webassembly metals
so be have the overhead when you're
cutting webassembly the JavaScript has
to convert your parameters to some kind
of representation in your in your
Austrian Graner meaning that if you are
for example in this case if you're
filtering and mapping on a list of
Android or thousand of objects and for
each of those objects that are Weber's
of the objects you're calling a method
like fun over here get type or get
variables that is giving you back a
string all of those things have to to
incur a cost of converting from
webassembly string when I suppress a
string to a JavaScript string and that
can take a bit of time in most cases in
what it won't be noticeable but still
might be a good idea to store things
like the strings or the value on the
dais side so don't you so that you don't
have to cross the gap between JavaScript
and the web assembly world every time
you are rendering a component sometimes
at some point you know your code base is
growing in my case as it's an
open-source software I'm getting
contributors and here here are a few
tips to keep your codebase saying the
first thing is to just have components
for everything if you have an alpha
button if you want to have this alpha
button that is a bit smaller on the
screen don't just add the font size 12
and and be done just create a new
component for it what I'm is saying
basically is our design system and stick
to it I'm not you didn't testing my
visual components sorry when actually I
do believe there are some pathways there
is logic what I do is to create visual
stories so using a storybook or reacts a
guy dist
you can create stories that are your
components walking outside of your
application so that you can work on them
and test them without ruining the whole
depiction it's very useful when for
example you want to test that you're
confident is displaying some kind of
Eros that you're not seeing in a real
because your software is working
properly that's a huge huge advantage of
a native development because you don't
have to relaunch your wall application
every time you're making some small
changes
and finally make sure to use types is a
flow or tie script I don't care just
types will tell you that you forget you
forget to pass a proper to remove a prop
it helps for to completion it avoiding
most silly mistake or not so silly
sometimes it documents the objects so I
think that types are early shining when
you or someone else is refactoring some
part of the app and remember that after
few months you will be a stranger to
your own code base this being said I
think that we have now the core of the
software that histones transpired to
webassembly we have a new interface done
using a react is just a few words about
packaging the whole thing you can either
package this as a progressive web app
using electron or even embed the whole
thing is in the native application
whatever you choose my advice is to
build over to existing API so for
example in electron you have API is to
make context menus better use them to
get a native feeling if you're
distributing your application as a
downloadable application so yeah that's
that seems to work let's let's see the
result so this is the new application
running in electron but that can run in
a web browser too and I'm doing the same
thing as before meaning that I'm
creating a button object and I would put
it on the screen and as before adding a
few visual events so that when I'm
stepping on the button then the platform
is going up in the air so yeah I'm
putting the button on the screen and
same thing as before I'm adding a new
event with a condition so that if there
is a collision between the player and
the the button then the platform will
move so can see that it's more is the
same thing it's a bit old actually so
the interface has been changing a bit
again but you can see that it's a bit
the same thing internally and yeah I can
press play the world
oh no sorry I forgot the second action
to change the state of the button so
yeah when I'm done I can press play and
the web assembly module will be
containing the world thing to to
JavaScript and you have a game running
and yeah that's that's working well or
at least for for my definition of a
developer it's working well what are the
users seen well be honest the first
feedback about the patient were already
bad why because people were used it was
not because it was done using electron
or reactor it was some kind of web
application it's just because even if
the curve the software was the same as
the previous version the word interface
was new and so I was missing features
and so people were complaining about
this lack of features and after a few
months of work adding new features back
like like the previous version people
started to say ok that's that that is
better that is better than the old
version I can even be more productive on
many aspect compared to the old version
and now people are almost entirely using
this new version compared to the old one
so it works it works so well that the
native app is better sorry native web
application is better than the entirely
native application why better because I
can iterate on it really fast ly because
rather than waiting for one minute for
the C++ code to compile whenever I'm
making a change to the interface I have
to wait only 10 seconds for a pack to
complete the wall fins and 10 seconds is
too it's too much no it's not that much
compared to before and I can test it
really fast using storybook I have a
near-perfect cross-platform almost no
issue no crush I can develop on Mac OS
and this related to Windows and we went
without even testing still doing some
tests I have as fast a lot of time
auto-updates most contributors I can try
it online I think that's something that
was not even possible before you can go
online and try the software we won't
even download it I can put it to a phone
and yeah it's actually working on a
phone it's not made for but I'm adapting
to interface so that we can can run
fairly well on a recent phone so I think
that's it I wanted to show with this
torque that we work with web
oh geez we can be ambitious and make
things that are as good if not better
than what we used to do in the native
world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]